when I'm playing the soccer I feel like
you know I'm different well
to see the future of america Modelo
looks not to its coast but to its heart
it's there that we found a competitive
community working together my name is
marcin Lally I'm from Somalia
last 25 years there's no government and
it was a lot of civil war going on and
suicide pum happened right next to where
I was so I have to learn that way from
that to save my life my name is angel
Mejia I'm from Honduras the reason why I
came to United States is because of the
gang members I seen people getting robs
that I had dreams that I was being
chased and killed you know I'm here and
I decided to be here for my life I wanna
have more people more community I have
to fight for that there's a time that
you need to fight for something else
Montgomery ergodicity we made the city
leaks and we go out there and we play
[Music]
Oh
and my Tennessee Mexicans Guatemalans
Salvadorians it's always a mix and it's
a good thing because you can learn from
each player I learned a lot of things
from people from another country they
taught me like their culture how to
change their hand we share a lot of
things if I go I'm gonna go 100 percent
on the field you have that competition
always I love to run now when I run I
feel free you know I forgot everything
bad that happened to me while I'm
playing soccer the malaise that we leave
we have to be a nation be united and we
get success that's why we come together
and play soccer
[Music]